tenemos cuatro triángulos aquí y nos
dicen que los triángulos no están
dibujados a escala y se nos pregunta que
par de triángulos es congruentes
así que pausa este vídeo y ver si puedes
resolverlo por tu cuenta antes de que lo
resolvamos juntos muy bien ahora
trabajemos juntos en esto parece que
para casi todos los triángulos nos
proporcionan dos ángulos y un lado
aunque para este triángulo y jh solo nos
han dado dos ángulos entonces si conozco
dos ángulos de un triángulo lo que me
gustaría hacer es calcular el tercer
ángulo porque la suma de los ángulos de
un triángulo tiene que ser igual a 180
grados y luego puedo usar esa
información tal vez con los lados que
nos dan para encontrar cuáles de estos
triángulos son congruentes en primer
lugar cuál sería la medida de este
ángulo la medida del ángulo acb pausa el
vídeo e intenta pensar en eso bueno una
forma de pensar en esto es que si
llamamos a la medida de este ángulo x
sabemos que x más 36 más 82
debe ser igual a 180 estas medidas son
en grados entonces podría decir x 36 82
es 118 lo hice bien 6 más 2 son 8 y 3
más 8 son 11 si es correcto eso será
igual a 180 y luego si restó 118 de
ambos lados obtendré que x es igual a
180 menos 118 que es 62 entonces esto es
x es igual a 62 como podemos decir que
es un ángulo de 62 grados podrías poner
todo en términos de grados si así lo
deseas muy bien ahora hagamos lo mismo
con este de aquí bueno este tiene un
ángulo de 82 grados y un ángulo de 62
grados al igual que este triángulo de
aquí entonces sabemos que el tercer
ángulo debe ser 36 grados porque sabemos
que si sumamos 82 y 62 y necesitamos
llegar a 180
tenemos que sumar 36 acabamos de
calcularlo en este primer triángulo
ahora si miramos aquí 36 grados y 59
definitivamente parece que tienen
ángulos diferentes pero descubramos cuál
debería ser este ángulo si llamamos a
este ángulo de grados lo haré aquí ya
más 36 59 es igual a 180 todo eso está
en términos de grados y más a que es
igual esto esto va a ser igual a 95 es
igual a 180 lo hice bien si esto es 80
más 15 si 95 y luego si restó 95 de
ambos lados que me queda me queda que es
igual a 85 grados esto será igual a 85
grados luego este último triángulo justo
aquí tiene un ángulo que mide 36 y otro
que es 59 y usando la misma lógica este
de aquí tiene que ser de 85 grados
entonces ahora que sabemos un poco más
sobre estos triángulos nos preguntamos
cuál de estos dos pares es congruente
quizá te veas tentado al ver estos dos
triángulos aquí abajo a decir oye veo
que todos sus ángulos son iguales
tenemos ángulo ángulo ángulo y ángulo
ángulo ángulo bueno serían semejantes si
tienes tres ángulos que son iguales
definitivamente tienes triángulos
semejantes pero no tenemos ninguna
información de longitud para el
triángulo y jh y necesitas conocer al
menos la longitud de uno de los lados
para poder considerar una congruencia
por lo que no podemos concluir que los
triángulos y jh y lmk sean congruentes
entre sí ahora veamos estos candidatos
aquí arriba sabemos que sus ángulos son
todos iguales por lo que podríamos
aplicar ángulo lo haré en un color
diferente ángulo lado ángulo 36 grados
longitud 6 82 grados 36 grados longitud
6 82 grados entonces por ángulo lado
ángulo
sabemos que el triángulo abc es
congruente con el triángulo d
y con esto terminamos